peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
helsinki stockholm vienne et clermont
ferrand tels seront les étapes de cette
tournée 80 en europe de la first lady of
jazz
une tournée qui ne sera pas la dernière
sur le vieux continent comme elle a tenu
à nous le préciser c'est la première
fois que je viens à clermont ferrand et
j'en suis très heureuse parce que j ai
de nombreux admirateurs
c'est formidable pour moi tu allais dans
des régions de france que je n'ai pas
encore visité tant que mon manager ne se
retirera pas et tant qu'il y aura des
gens pour m'écouter je serais heureux de
venir leur rendre visite à plus de 60
ans ella fitzgerald affiche encore une
belle santé elle sera ce soir sur la
scène de la maison des congrès devant
quelque 13 cents privilégiés
la norme fait que
[Musique]